It's not until the fourth book of Paradise lost that we see.
Finally,
we see represented before us.
The paradise who's imminent loss is,
is heralded.
So grandly in the poems title and,
and Milton's task here is a difficult one.
His task is to,
is to represent unfollowing Eden Eden before the fall,
to represent this unfollow needing to a fallen audience of the 1660s from his
own perspective as a fallen,
as a fallen man himself as a fallen poet.
And Milton is continually confronting his self conscious about this predicament
and continually confronting the challenge posed by this essentially artistic
predicament.
But the predicament is not simply,
although it is this not simply an epistomological quandary.
I'm a problem about knowledge.
How can fallen man know anything about unfollowed?
Man,
there's,
there's more writing on this question than merely the,
uh,
this,
this question of how can we possibly know what it was like in this unknowable
state before the fall?
And it's,
it's more important than simply that because everything is riding on Milton
success,
uh,
of,
of his representation of,
of an unfollowing Eden.
I think the theodicy,
the success of Milton's attempt to justify the ways of God to men is hanging to
s to some degree on the success of his representation of unfollowing us.
And,
and this is why,
because only if we can truly see paradise as an fallen can.
We really believe that Adam and eve were in fact perfectly capable of exercising
their unfolding wills freely when confronted with the temptation of the,
of the fruit.
So even so much as a hint of,
of fallenness in a representation of Eden threatens to threatens,
to indict God,
threatens to impugn God's justice.
And because God can be said to have caused the fall,
if he can be seen to have insinuated into paradise,
even the slightest propensity to,
to fall on us.
Um,
this the,
the question is an important one.
So to justify fully the ways of God that this fallen poet has to represent to us
the fallen audience and Eden,
that is unmistakably unfollow,
fallen.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a huge challenge.
Um,
and,
and though an unfolding Eden,
Eden can't be like anything we know.
Um,
it,
it has to be utterly other from everything that we're familiar with because of
course everything that we're familiar with is fallen.
And so one of the dominant rhetorical strategies of the first two books has to
be inverted to some degree.
In,
in book four.
Um,
we have spent some time to talking about the similes,
especially the similes at the beginning of Milton's poem.
And the similar use initially,
um,
in,
in paradise lost is at some important junctures in book four especially,
is transformed into what we can think of as a dissimilarly.
I'm not actually sure that that's a real rhetorical term.
Um,
I didn't make it up,
but in any case,
we'll,
we'll use it for,
for lack of a better,
lack of a better word.
Um,
so,
uh,
similarly,
positive simile involves the construct.
You know what this is like,
it involves a construction that x is like why and a dissimilar would propose the
opposite.
That x is unlike why.
And so I'm going to ask you to turn to the most famous of these dissimilarities
and paradise lost.
This is at line two 68 of book for um,
it's page two 83 and two 84 in the Hughes.
And Milton is forced to describe what else can he do.
He's forced to describe paradise in terms of all the things that Eden is not.
So he tells us not that Fairfield of Ena nor that sweet grove of Daphne by
warranties nor that nicey and aisle.
I'm skipping here obviously,
and,
and so forth.
It's quite a catalog of things that Eden is not Mike and the rhetorical mode is
necessarily one of,
uh,
of negation because of the epistomological and artistic problem of,
of the fallen representation of unfollowing us.
Look,
um,
look a little further up at line two or 33.
This is I think where the problem of a,
of a fallen representation of an unfollow on state actually really comes to a
head Milton's describing here the four rivers of Eden,
a line two 33 and now divided into four main streams,
run diverse wandering,
many of famous realm and country.
And where up here needs no account but rather to tell if art could tell how from
that Sapphire found the crisp had Brooks rolling on Orient Pearl and sands of
gold with Maisie.
Error under didn't shades ran nectar visiting each plant and Fed flowers worthy
of paradise,
which not nice art in beds and curious knots.
But nature boom poured forth Prefuse on hill and Dale and plane,
the flowers,
a paradise or poured forth in Eden,
not by a nice or a or a fastidious,
uh,
a Gardner by fastidious artifice.
Um,
there's,
there's nothing fussy about this garden.
It's bounty as nature herself who has poured forth all this pro fused.
Snus Eden is free of any artifice.
And,
but this lack of art in Eden of course only accentuates the problem that the
poet has no choice but to face,
um,
that the poet is under a pressure to describe with of what is of course his
poetic art that which is essentially indescribable.
And Milton lets us know the problem if art could tell.
And that phrase,
if art could tell clearly implies that aren't even Milton's aren't a,
can't tell us what Eden was like.
The Milton's aren't,
can't represent an unfollowing non artificial world with the instruments,
the tools of fallen artificial language and the,
the,
the impossibility of that he's facing I think is nowhere so impair a parent as
it is here in this description of the Crisper Brooks of paradise rolling with
Maisie error underpinned in shades.
Now of course,
error is a,
one of the most resident resident words in the entire poem.
Um,
error is the moral category or that we can think of it as the theological
category most often applied to the fall and to Adam and Eve's eventual sin.
And we might very well wonder why it is that error has,
has,
has crept into Eden before the fall.
It's presence here on some level,
it could be seen to doom the garden in advance.
It could be seen as some kind of evidence of a,
of a degree of fallenness in this unfolding Eden.
But Milton of course is using the word error in a special sense.
[inaudible] and he's doing what he does.
So often he's,
he employs a word solely to evoke its etymological root sense.
Uh,
which in this case simply means wandering.
The brook here is quite simply not flowing straight.
It's warm.
It's,
it's moving.
it's devastating.
It's moving in a,
in a,
in a curvaceous form.
And Milton is working consciously to exclude the,
the moral significance that this word error had acquired later in its,
in its etymological history.
I mean,
he's attempting to block out the meaning of this word that had crept in as it
were after the fall.
There's actually a wonderful book that looks really gently at just this
phenomenon.
It's called Milton's grand style,
uh,
by,
by the great critic Christopher ricks.
Um,
and,
and in that book,
Rick's argues for the,
the self consciousness behind Milton's employment of the original etymological
sense of some of the most loaded words in the,
in the poem.
And so Milton will remind us of the fall with his use of such a word as,
as error.
But if it's at the same time,
of course he's attempting to create an us and it's a remarkable move to create
in us a memory for a time in which a word like error had not yet been infected
by it's morally pejorative,
modern connotation.
He's reminding us of a time in which there was no such thing as moral error.
Not that we can be reminded because we,
of course we can't remember,
we weren't around,
but it's as if a memory is being instilled in us by means of Milton's poetry.
Um,
he,
he condenses into a single word what does essentially the entire poetic problem,
but setting the description of a,
of an fallen Eden Milton to manages with a word like this to remind us that
we're only seeing the garden after Satan has overlapped its boundaries and is
in,
has begun sneaking around and were given no description.
You'll,
you'll note we getting rid of no description of Eden until after the point in
the story in which Satan has already entered or cross the boundaries of
Paradise.
Look at a line to 85.
This is page two 85 in the Hughes.
Milton locates that geographical spot on the globe,
uh,
believed to have been eaten,
but he does that only to remind us that everything that we're saying is
precisely what Satan is seeing,
where the fiend saw an delighted all delight,
all kind of creatures,
new to site and strange.
And Satan's presence isn't as important here because he reminds us that we too
are,
we're in,
we're in a position of seeing and delighted all delight.
We share his paint alienation,
um,
from the,
from the innocence of the garden.
And,
and nowhere is the problem of representation more urgent and more troubled than
in the first view that we're given of of Adam and eve.
There is an extraordinary pressure on Milton as he describes the condition of
the and fallen Adam and eve and,
and,
and that pressure would unquestionably,
I think have been felt by the poems original or original readers,
Milton's description of Adam and eve.
And in this respect it is like what I take to be nearly every 17th century
description of Adam and eve.
It's,
it is necessarily a political statement.
It's an account of a first,
it's the account of the first society.
And as an account of the first society,
Milton's Eaton has to establish something like the ideal against which all
current,
all fallen societies have to be judged.
Um,
so in the 17th century or a description of man and the state of nature before
the onset of any kind of civil government was an essential component component
of about just about any political philosophy.
You couldn't,
you couldn't forward a political vision without forwarding at the same time an
image of a society before the onset of government.
And the most important political philosopher of mid,
mid 17th century England,
um,
is Milton's slightly older contemporary Thomas Hobbs.
And he had founded his vision of politics,
which was a decidedly authoritarian vision of politics on just such an account
of a nearly unrecoverable on unremembered bubble past.
And so we,
in in Hobbs is Leviathan.
Um,
Hobbes conjures image of the original,
the original man in the state of nature that serves as the foundation for his,
uh,
political wisdom for his truly outrageous thesis that the only viable political
institution is that of an absolutist monarchy.
And I say it's,
it's a,
I say it's outrageous perhaps because it's so incredibly compelling.
Um,
you,
you almost,
uh,
it's,
it's very hard not to be converted to a,
a terrifying form of authoritarianism when you,
when you read Hobbes is iron clad,
uh,
pros.
So in the famous chapter 13 of the first book of Leviathan,
this was in the,
in the packet hubs describes the riot is mayhem constituent of life before the
onset of political institutions.
And so interestingly and importantly,
here Hobbs is forwarding a kind of secular argument.
This isn't theological.
And so he doesn't return us to the genesis account of Adam and eve.
Um,
his is the state of nature.
He tells us it's just like the one inhabited.
It's,
it's,
it's America.
Um,
it's the one inhabited by the savages of,
of,
of the Americas.
But the purpose is the purpose of the hubs and account is directly analogous.
I think to Milton's purpose in describing Eden for Hobbs,
uh,
men in the state of nature are all equal.
The state of nature is an egalitarian one.
And,
and,
and Hobbes does everything he can do it.
It's egalitarian even with respect to sex.
And,
and Hobbes does everything you can do to demonstrate the dangers of this natural
egalitarianism.
Because,
uh,
because Hobbes tells us all men and women are,
were created equal.
There's no authority to keep them in place.
There's no,
there's no authority to keep them from what would it naturally just be a
perpetual state of strife.
And so,
uh,
and so hubs,
hubs explains in chapter 13,
without a common power and by common power,
he means a king,
a prince,
a tyrant.
It doesn't matter.
Someone without a common power man is in the state of war.
And such a war is as is,
as is of every man against every man.
And he continues.
And the life of the natural man.
And this is surely the most famous and the most glorious sentence in all of
Hobbs is remarkable Leviathan.
And the life of the natural man is solitary,
poor,
nasty,
brutish and short.
And so for hubs,
the egalitarianism established in nature is obviously on satisfactory.
It has to be corrected.
And so we have to construct some kind of governmental structure,
apology where whereby we submit ourselves to an absolute ruler,
a monarch or a tire,
and it doesn't matter.
And Hobbes,
Leviathan must have been deeply troubling to Milton,
um,
who devoted so much of his career,
to the critique of just the kind of absolute us government that Hobbes is
championing.
And I think there are a lot of signs and paradise lost that Milton is countering
his great contemporary Thomas Hobbs.
Now one of the advantages of writing about,
about Eden was that a description of paradise,
as I've suggested,
was something like an implicit model for a political philosophy.
It's certainly a Milton's hands.
And so Hobbes had used his description of the f the state of men in the state of
nature to forward his,
his authoritarianism.
And,
and so Milton has to use his description of the first couple to forward his
cause,
which is essentially that of republicanism or some kind of non monarchic
government and Adam and eve have to form,
they have to be able to form a successful society alone,
a successful polity on their own without the dictatorial intervention of any
sovereign power.
This is crucial for,
for,
for what Milton needs to be able to argue politically.
So what exactly your Milton's politics?
It's been a while since we visited this topic.
Um,
we haven't,
we haven't really discussed Milton's politics since we looked at the 1644 area
[inaudible] and a lot I'm sad to say has changed since then.
In areopagite it could be seven Milton affirm what was essentially the general
equality of all human beings.
And this was an implicit argument that all individuals have been endowed by God
with reason and that they are all equally capable of choosing and reasoning for
themselves.
But in the 1650s,
Milton had grown considerably less optimistic.
Um,
and his sense of the equality of,
of all men and women,
the average individual in England,
uh,
for Milton at this point didn't in fact seem to be endowed with quite as much
reason and capacity for rational choice as Milton felt that he was capable of or
as mill some felt that he and his fellow Puritan Revolutionaries,
um,
we're,
we're capable of so many of Milton's backsliding country men wanted their king
back,
a devastating a cultural fact for Milton.
And so Milton began to develop something,
a,
a new political philosophy.
And it's something like an aristocratic philosophy of political society that
places superior,
more rational,
more spiritually minded beings.
People like John Milton,
I'm at the top of this society.
And they,
um,
are necessarily above less rational,
less excellent,
uh,
less spiritually minded beings who are obviously,
um,
in a lower stratum.
And so Milton Milton's later political philosophy sketches something like an
almost a natural hierarchy in which the rational elite are in a position to
guide and to,
uh,
to offer some sort of authoritative wisdom to the less rational members of this
society.
And these less rational member ideally willingly,
willingly yield to the superior wisdom and the reason of the rational elite it
would.
And it seems to be this later vision of a kind of naturally hierarchical society
that forms the basis for the first polity,
which is that of Adam and eve in Milton's Eden.
And it goes without saying.
The Union of Adam and Eve in Milton's paradise is a,
is a patriarchal one.
And the hierarchical division between superior and inferior creatures,
um,
has been marked almost entirely or exclusively along the lines of gender.
I mean,
Milton as you know,
has been reviled for his unrepentant patriarchal.
One of the first couple.
Um,
he,
he looked at line two 99,
one of the most famous lines in the poem.
Um,
this is the middle of page two,
85 of the Hughes.
Milton's talking about,
uh,
the purpose of Adam and Eve's creation.
He forgot only she forgotten him.
It,
this is a,
this is without question a,
a sexist,
sexist vision of the first polity.
We can say that I think without much hesitation,
but it would be almost criminal.
And I really believe this to say that Milton sexism is simplistic.
Um,
it is so complex in fact that Milton has included in his poem,
um,
a number of competing ways to think about this,
this first society.
And we actually have passionately expressed before us in paradise lost,
um,
the old Milton,
the younger,
much more liberal Milton,
that radically Galatarian ism that he was able so forcefully and compellingly to
voice scenario politica that voice is audible and paradise lost.
But we also of course have the later Milton,
the believer in a hierarchical society.
And,
and you can hear this,
these contradictions at work in the poems description of this first polity that
the union of Adam and eve.
So look a little further up on page two 85.
This is line two 88
two of far nobler shape,
erect dental,
godlike,
erect with native honor,
clad in Naked Majesty,
seemed lords of all.
And were these seemed for in their looks divine,
the image of their glorious makers,
Sean,
truth,
wisdom,
sanctitude severe and pure severe but in true filial freedom placed when it's
truth whence true authority and men.
Now I,
it certainly strikes me to be the case that this first few that we get of Adam
and eve is an egalitarian one.
They are both in there Naked Majesty.
They are both described as lords of all,
but they're,
that they're seeming a quality is,
is a,
is a source of no small anxiety to Milton.
And so we are told almost immediately he can't take it anymore.
Um,
we're,
we're told though both not equal as their sex,
not equal scene.
Well of course up to this point,
their sex did equal seam and it's here that Milton places an enormous amount of
weight on this word seemed one of the most important words in book four seemed,
seemed,
seemed not equal to whom the idea of seeming is always with respect to a
perceiver,
um,
someone to whom something seems to be this or that and it's with this word seem
that were reintroduced to the subject of the fallen perspective on and fallen
scene and reminded that we are not granted anything like a purview of Eden until
after Satan,
Satan has,
has entered the garden.
And,
and,
and in book this description of Eden in book four has in fact merely been
tracing Satan's steps.
And this description of Adam and eve merely emerges now because this is the
scene that Satan happens now to be looking at.
I look at line two 85 I've already,
I've already referred to these lines where the fiend saw an delighted all
delight,
all kind of living creatures,
new decide and strange.
And then you have a colon and then after the colon falls,
this long description of Adam and eve.
And it's possible,
it's just possible to read the entire description of the sexually hierarchized
Adam and Eve as an account,
as an account in something like indirect discourse of Satan's fallen
perspective.
If their sex not equals seemed,
it's possible that their sex not equal seemed to Satan and it,
and it's Satan.
Of course,
we know this already to be the case.
Who is more concerned than any of the other poems,
characters with problems of inequality.
So this is,
this is naturally going to be the predisposition set of concerns that he brings
to his vision of any polity.
There's,
there's,
it's a,
it's a fascinating question and there's actually a considerable debate raging
after we can,
if you can say that,
uh,
Milton just rage.
But if,
uh,
there's a,
there's a debate among meltedness on just this question and it's an interesting
one.
Milton's position at the head of the English literary Canon is often associated
or has been since the late seventies with his insistent positioning or maybe
actually since Virginia Woolf was writing in the twenties and thirties is often
associated with his is insistent positioning of Adam over eve in,
in paradise lost.
And so some participants in the debates about the,
the,
the validity of the western literary canon have imagined the effects of sexism,
sexism in our society,
um,
have imagined eradicating sexism,
sexism in our society by eradicating from college reading lists.
I'm a sexist poet,
light like,
like Milton.
And that argument is made,
it's still forwarded today and it's an argument poses as you can imagine,
it poses an understandable threat to,
uh,
to people like me admirers of this poet.
And you can imagine the number of Milton assists.
It was really quite remarkable who rallied around the textual suggestion that,
that when Milton says he forgot,
only she forgotten him,
he doesn't really mean it.
Uh,
this was,
uh,
I think it was in the mid eighties that a critic first first hit on the theory
that all of the description of Adam and eve could be seen as a,
as merely an exfoliation of the,
of Satan's perspective.
And there was a tremendous joy and excitement and the miltonic,
but then the Milton community,
once that idea had been,
had been floated,
um,
it's as if the narrator is just reproducing for us the hierarchical imagination
of Satan who's perspective on Adam and Eve is the one that we're getting at the
moment.
And so we're able to say to ourselves rather comfortably and complacently that
Milton isn't telling us that,
uh,
that,
that the Social Organization of Eden is sexist and Milton is telling us that
Satan is sexist and that Patriarchy is essentially satanic rather than miltonic.
Um,
it's,
it's a,
it's a depressing,
I get depressed when I think of,
um,
positions,
critical positions like this.
Um,
whether you have the extreme position of Milton as the inventor and the prime
perpetrator of misogyny on the one hand or the counter vision of Milton as an
early feminist on,
on the other.
Um,
the case is obviously more complicated than that.
And it's more interesting than that because it's not at all clear in the,
and just in the passage that we're looking at,
it's not clear whose voice is actually authorizing these lines that established
the patriarchal PR parameters of unfollowing society with without a doubt,
we have,
uh,
the narrator speaking here and presumably he is representing something like the
official line of the poem.
But Milton does in fact go out of his way to situate the entire scene as an
elaboration of Satan's perspective.
Both of these things are true and this passage,
which has absolutely everything to do with the established,
with what Milton calls,
establishing the true authority of men.
This passage refuses to establish its own authority.
It refuses to announce itself as the product either of,
of,
of the poems,
narrator or,
or,
or of Satan.
And,
and this,
it's a,
it's a moment of textual instability and it reflects the larger,
I think it reflects the larger political instability that is threatening Eden,
threatening the relationship,
the relation between Adam and eve.
And so it's worth asking ourselves,
what is it about Adam and eve that makes them seem on equal?
Look at line two 97
for contemplation.
He and Valerie are formed for softness.
She and sweet,
attractive grace.
Now,
how do we,
how do we know this?
We know it by their physical differences.
Uh,
we know it by the appearance of their anatomies and more precisely than that,
we know that they are different and unequal,
um,
by means of our perception of their hair,
his fair,
large front.
And I sublime declare absolute rule and highest and theme locks round from his
parted forelock manly hung clustering but not beneath his shoulders.
Um,
Milton did wear his hair long,
but he wants us to know that's,
that's,
that's part of the historical record.
And he was very pleased with that.
Um,
but he wants to,
he always wants us to know that it wasn't too long.
And this,
it's the same with Adam who wears his hair unusually long but not in decorously
long,
um,
round from his part in forelock,
manly hung clustering but not beneath his shoulders broad.
She as a veil down to the slender waste.
Her unadorned had golden tresses war disheveled,
but in wanton ringlets waived as the vine curls her tendrils
which implied subjection.
Now I,
I,
I'll,
I'll bet that we can all agree that a description of their hair is not what we
were expecting at this moment.
Um,
supporters of Patriarchy or of the sexual superior,
though it's the superiority of men have always enlisted anatomical differences.
Uh,
the anatomical differences between the sexes as proof of of man's rightful,
a rightful ability to subject or subordinate woman.
And in fact central to the patriarchal prejudice,
as you can imagine,
was the strength diff.
What it's often seems to be the strength differential between men and women.
And so with Milton had imagined a cosmos that privileged physical strength,
then I think we would have no choice but glumly to accept the fact that Adam is
indeed superior to eve.
And you could imagine how an argument like this could,
it could have played out in the pages of paradise lost if a at Milton could
easily have argued that human excellence could be determined by the sheer number
of shrubs that Adam and eve were able to prune on any given day.
And so in,
in,
in such a world,
I'm Adam would be able to prove his superiority,
but physical strength and this is important means absolutely nothing and
paradise lost.
And in fact,
if anything,
Milton is always denigrating the importance of physical strength.
So why?
Okay.
Given that we still have to ask the question,
why try to argue for the inequality of the sexes on the basis of hair length?
Um,
you,
I presume that none of you have had,
but you probably still know nonetheless,
that men and women or boys and girls are not born with distinct or
distinguishable heads of hair.
Um,
at least until male pattern baldness sets in there.
Uh,
the,
the head,
the hair of men and women aren't distinct,
are distinguishable.
And if anything,
male pattern baldness simply gives women an edge.
And if Milton wanted to use Harris and natural sign of sexual difference,
he should be discussing,
I would think he should be discussing facial hair,
Adam's superiority,
um,
presumably could be advanced by his commanding beard.
We could imagine Milton doing that,
something that he lacks by virtue of her anatomy.
But the hair on the head,
this doesn't make any sense.
The hair on the head is in fact one of the few anatomical features that is
absolutely gender neutral.
Our hair is gendered by virtue of the Barber,
not by virtue of the Creator,
which brings us to this fact,
um,
which we all know,
the obvious and w which is what every obstetrician knows,
the obvious distinguishing anatomical correct characteristic his genitalia.
Um,
and Milton actually does mention Adam and Eve's mysterious parts,
but,
but he mentioned them only to dismiss their difference.
Um,
he may be gesturing towards something like,
you'll tell me if this is crazy,
if something like a genital difference when he describes Adam's hair,
his locks,
manly,
hung,
clustering.
I,
I'm,
I don't,
I don't think that,
I don't think that holds,
that the sexual signifier
that hangs manly off of Adam's body and that signifier,
which has traditionally of course been invoked as a sign of sexual superiority
is Adam's penis.
But Milton alludes to this genital signifier of difference.
They're mysterious parts only to dismiss it.
He chooses instead for the distinguishing characteristic of the sexes of
phenomenon that's rooted not in nature but in culture.
Hairline,
like,
like Hobbes.
Milton is under a tremendous cultural pressure.
And when he describes the earliest state of nature,
um,
the description of nature has to bear the weight of all of the social and all of
the political claims that the poem makes.
And the set of social conditions that,
that Milton has to justify and make seem natural is,
is a particularly tricky one.
Both even Adam have to be seen as absolutely free.
Each of them has to be capable of exercising reason and making a reasonable
rational decisions.
And in this sense,
Adam and joy,
Adam and eve joy,
something like the absolutely egalitarian world,
the structure of the political world that we had seen in the treatise
[inaudible] Politica Milton at his most exuberantly liberal.
But while Adam and eve enjoy all the rights of an egalitarian society as they
do,
I think in paradise lost,
they are not therefore equal.
Adam appears to be superior to eve.
And Milton will only tell us that he appears such the,
the,
the narrator cannot make this,
uh,
make this claim in anything like a more declarative sense.
And so on the basis of,
at least at least of their appearances,
the social formation in Eden is strictly hierarchical and on some extraordinary
level,
this poem is trying to have it both ways.
And so much of the energy of the account of paradise derives from Milton's
contradictory account of the political structure of Eden.
He applies to the Edenic society of Adam and Eve.
What I take to be two irreconcilable modes of social governance,
Eden is once egalitarian it's inhabitants or,
or entire,
there may in Naked Majesty there,
lords of all,
both of them.
Uh,
Adam and eve are entirely free and self-determining,
but at the same time,
even as structured as a,
as a kind of aristocracy where the male class is deemed categorically
genetically superior to the female class and with a,
it goes without saying that this situation is untenable.
The contradictory social formation of paradise is inherently unstable.
And I'm convinced that nothing is more important in our understanding of the
dynamics of the fall.
Then this,
then these principles,
the principle that Eve is absolutely free and equally rational,
equally capable of rational and virtuous choices,
but also the conflicting principle that eve is to some extent subject to Adams
Adams Authority and the contradictory political impulses in the poem or are
brilliantly worked out in the first description of Adam and eve.
Look at,
look at line three Oh seven.
This is unbelievable.
Um,
look at what Milton is able to establish by way of a description of Eve's hair.
It's here in a representation of her hair that the nature of the Edenic polity
is established.
So eves golden tresses waived as the vine curls her tendrils,
which implied subjection but required with gentle sway.
And by her yielded by him.
Best received,
yielded with Khoi submission,
modest pride.
And isn't this a beautiful line and sweet,
reluctant amorous delay that the conflicting politics of even our best captured
in the,
in,
in by means of the rhetorical strategy of oxymoron or the or the contradiction
in terms Milton packs this description of the first couples.
This is essentially a kind of erotic play that's being described before us and
it's packed with oxymoron,
moronic descriptions and Milton's trying to communicate the incredibly delicate
political balance of this hierarchical society.
This society may be hierarchical,
Milton is telling us,
but it's not authoritarian eve maybe subject to Adam who holds authority over
eve but,
but,
but her subjection because she's free,
her subjection is required with a gentle sway and no sooner has Adam exercises
authority by gently swaying eve.
Then she willingly yields to him exercising her free capacity for,
for consent,
her capacity to choose to be swayed by her superior.
So Eve Sarah Harris seems to imply subjection,
but Eve's here also seems to imply freedom and to kind of resistance to
subjection.
Eve yields not with submission.
Milton would never permit himself to say that,
uh,
eve yields with a Koi submission.
She hold something back even as she grants it.
And we have detailed before us the endless give and take that this delicate
political structure requires.
And,
and for Milton,
this give and take is not only the basis of a society,
it's the basis as well for,
for,
for Eros four or sexual,
uh,
sexual pleasure.
With that,
that extraordinary phrase,
sweet,
reluctant,
Amaris Delay [inaudible] was able to pack into three adjectives and one noun.
The pleasure derived by both parties in Eve's exercise of resistance,
but [inaudible] is,
isn't just sexy for Milton,
it's also politically meaningful.
And from a political perspective,
her capacity for a kind of reluctance and resistance serves as a guarantee for
her capacity for our kind of rational consent.
And,
and,
and it's also theologically a resonant from a theological perspective.
Eves willingness to resist to delay constitutes a guarantee of her divinely
granted freewill.
It Eve cannot be forced to do anything.
And it's as if in this little dance that they perform in the quotidian life of,
of unfollowing Eden,
um,
eve is practicing in a small way for that crucial moment at the temptation in
which your ability to resist and delay will,
will mean the difference between life and death.
Now we as readers find it difficult.
I think we should at least find it difficult to found a theory of hierarchy on
something so fragile and so easily alterable you can tell I'm just,
I,
I just had a haircut yesterday,
so easily alterable as,
as hair length.
But what's even more amazing than that is that the fact that the nature of the
gendered hierarchy of Adam and Eve isn't even evident to Adam and eve
themselves.
Uh,
this blows me away.
Look at,
look at EBS.
First memory in paradise lost.
This is a line for 77.
Page two 89 in the Hughes eve is far from being able to recognize Adam
superiority immediately.
And for Eve,
there's certainly nothing in the length of his hair that,
that suggests that he might enjoy a kind of authority over her.
Um,
and in fact to eve,
Adam seems to be a noticeably inferior creature when she compares him to that
image of herself,
that beautiful and responsive image to her of herself that she had found in the
pool.
This is line for 77 till I,
she tells Adam till I aspire to be fair indeed and tall.
She said she grants him that he's tall under a plate and yet me thought less
fair,
less winning,
soft,
less amiably mild than that's smooth watery image.
It's like the,
it's like the dissimilarly of the Fairfield's of Ana.
Adam can only be understood by what it is he lacks.
And indeed it's a lack of anything like a natural or self evidence,
sexual hierarchy that constitutes one of the central problems.
And Paradise lost hierarchy is not a natural fact in,
in paradise.
It's an arbitrarily imposed social institution.
It's been imposed by God,
but it's,
it hasn't been built into the structure of the natural world.
And its to Milton's great credit.
And I really mean this,
I mean this with the utmost seriousness that he labors to expose the artificial
cultural origins of the sexual subjection,
that at the same time he is championing and celebrating.
Yves has to be told that Adam is her superior and she has to undergo a,
uh,
an elaborate process and a complicated process of,
of cultural indoctrination and nowhere in the description of Eden or we reminded
more forcefully of our incapacity to understand unfollow nature than in Milton's
description of EBS hair,
her unadorned,
a golden tresses ward disheveled,
but in wanton ringlets waived,
disheveled and want.
And of course these seem like extraordinarily prejudicial adjectives and they
cast a moral judgment.
It has seemed to readers from the very beginning.
They cast a moral judgment on her long before she has sinned.
But once again,
Milton is playing with that apology.
And I think this is Rick says,
point disheveled is being used here in its original literal sense.
It literally means hair let down and,
and the ringlets,
he's not wearing a bun and the ringlets are wanting anthem in that they are
simply unrestrained.
And,
and the fact that we are so eager as readers to supply a kind of loose their
sexual meaning to these words implicates us.
Milton perhaps seems to be saying it in an implicates of course,
Satan as well in the fallen perspective,
on the ultimate ultimately mysterious union of Adam and eve.
We are eyeing the muscats and leering at them just to is,
and,
and it Stanley Fischer's argument,
and it's not unconvincing that Milton's purpose in employing these loaded
adjectives is to force the reader to acknowledge her,
own her own fallenness,
um,
to remind us all of the inadequacy of our fallen perspective on,
on this unfollow nature.
So we're wrong to import a kind of moral prejudice to the words disheveled and
wanton.
But Milton,
we'll push it even further.
Um,
Eve's hair is also waiving and insinuating and in it's waving curly motions.
It resembles nothing so much as that other much less noble creature in the
garden.
And that's,
um,
that's of course the serpent.
Look at line three 45.
This is where Milton describes the elephant in the circle.
And I don't have time to comment at all.
I just want to say what an amazing adjective.
The unwieldy elephant,
the unwieldy elephant to make them mirth used all his might and read to his live
Probasco this close the serpent,
sly insinuating wove with Gordian twine,
his braided train,
the braided train of the serpents waving motion resembles nothing so much as the
waving braids of Eve's hair and eve seems to be associated well in advance of
the actual temptation with the sly insinuations of the serpent and association
that of course can only damage any sense that we have of her unfollowing reason
and her her genuine freewill.
But Milton carefully includes in this description another example of a waving
and insinuating motion and Eden.
And that's the elephants proboscis.
He's prefaced his connection between even Satan here,
um,
with the,
with the inclusion of the elephant.
He wants us to know with this image of the elephants light Probasco is that the
motion of waving and weaving and reading and insinuating are still in fact
entirely innocent.
And it will be only be Satan's subsequent actions that and infect them retro
retroactively infect them for us.
And,
and the problem being exposed once again is the problem of representation.
How can you represent an unfolded state from a fallen perspective?
Okay.
Um,
look at your,
the handout.
And if you don't have a handout,
um,
try to get one from the corners of the room.
Uh,
at this,
this representation of Adam and Eve was made in 1638.
Um,
so this is this Rembrandt did this drawing,
uh,
shortly before Milton was beginning to think of paradise lost.
And in the Rembrandt representation we have,
I think this is a devastating critique of the 17th century desire to represent
an unfollowing paradise.
But we have Milton trying to do like Milton represent a Rembrandt exposes the
impossibility I think of of such a representation.
Uh,
if we read the book of Genesis,
we know that,
that he was alone with the serpent.
And so we're seeing Adam and eve in this picture presumably after eve is eaten
the fruit,
but before Adam had eaten it,
now Adam May not have eaten the fruit,
but he certainly,
I mean,
look at,
look at this.
He certainly looks as fallen as eve.
There.
They are equally physically ugly,
it seems to me.
And that's indisputable,
nasty,
brutish and short.
It's as if they've crawled out of the pages of the famous 13th chapter of the
first book of Hobbs' Leviathan look at eaves face with its broad overhanging
brow.
She suggested the uninvolved,
a state of an upper primate more than she does of the Glorious and beautiful
first human female.
And looking at them that they're presumably on fallen.
Adam here is riding in a twisted and guilty posture that gives him no moral,
superior superiority over eb whatsoever.
And it,
and if anything here,
Adam's here seems more wanton and more disheveled then eaves,
um,
Rembrandt's even seems to be,
must be very humid.
There's a kind of frizzy split end thing going on,
uh,
with,
with both of them and especially with the,
but at least it's falling rather neatly over her head,
which cannot be said of Adam.
And of course the primary clue that this representation of Eden is imposing
upon.
Yeah.
Uh,
unfollow and Adam,
a sense of fallenness comes from Rembrandt shading of their genitals.
And,
and actually in the original you can,
you can make out their genitalia quite,
quite distinctly,
but they're nonetheless Jaden and this shaded,
this is it.
This is important for Rembrandt.
They're partially hidden by the dark and guilty shadow produced by the serpent.
And the serpent you may or may not have noticed is that scaly hideous creature.
I'm climbing the tree on the right.
Uh,
Milton had gone out of his way to insist that the genitals of Adam and eve,
they're mysterious parts were not concealed.
But then he goes on to,
since you're us,
his fallen readers for the sense of guilty shame that we bring to any
speculation about their mysterious parts,
but Rembrandt is,
it's as if Mitt Rembrandts a step ahead of Milton.
He's telling us that there can be no such thing as a just representation of
unfollow.
Nudity are,
are darkened minds,
will continually shade that nudity with the,
with the inescapable shadows of guilt and shame that we have no choice but to
bring two questions of sexuality.
Rembrandt joins Milton in representing a scene that seems to lie somewhere.
Both the Eden of Rembrandt in the Eden of Milton seem to lie somewhere between a
fallen and an unfolding state.
And I think a lot of the energy of the Rembrandt drawing derives from his
refusal to depict the,
the moral superiority of one sex over the other.
There there's,
there,
there's no clear demarcation here of a sexual hierarchy or a natural sexual
hierarchy.
This Adam doesn't seem in,
he's physically stronger than eve and if he is to be seen as the greater sex,
perhaps it's just because he's placed himself arbitrarily in a physical posture
of superiority.
He's placed one foot slightly on a,
on a,
on an elevated play,
and he's trying to get a leg up.
Um,
he's compensating perhaps for his lack of a self evident authority over eve
tradition,
of course,
has always insisted,
and this is the story that we inherit as children,
that Eve's seduced Adam into eating the fruit.
Adam would never have fallen if even if eve hadn't tricked him into eating the
apple or implored her to join,
implored him to join her in her sin.
But Rembrandt here is refusing to attribute all of the guilty eve.
Now Adam May be,
it's possible that Adam is here trying to protect eve from the fruit with the
gesture of his hand,
but he also might be reaching for the fruit grabbing it.
Um,
it's possible that he's seizing the fruit just as Milton's Adam sees as eve when
he finds her by the pool.
So what I'm saying here is that the suggestion and both Milton and Rembrandt is
that the fall has less to do with eve seduction,
seduction of Adam.
Then the more foundational,
the structural problem of sexual inequality,
um,
the fall starts to look more and more like something like,
like the inevitable consequence of sexual hierarchy.
Okay.
Um,
I'm going to conclude after we take one final look at the Rembrandt at,
at one of the visual,
at the,
at the visual details that Milton forces,
um,
that Rembrandt forces into a kind of analogous relation.
And in this,
he's like Milton Milton.
Rembrandt draws into the relation into an analogous relation,
the slithery length of that awful serpent and the innocent and playful winding
of the elephants Probasco this.
And you can see the unwieldy elephant in the lower right hand corner of the
Rembrandt drawing.
Um,
but the,
the PROBASCO send the serpent's tail are not the only snaky things in
Rembrandt's Eden.
As,
as,
as I mentioned earlier,
and the original drawings,
Adam's mysterious part is actually quite visible.
It's nasty,
it's brutish,
it's short,
but it's discernible and it's important that is discernible.
And through this technique of visual juxtaposition,
Rembrandt casts and evil and satanic shadow over this part of Adam's anatomy,
that distinguishing feature of his sex,
which is the arbitrary signifier of his authority over eve.
So Adam's authority here in its most intimate manifestation may be as complicit
as the serpent in the crime of the fall.
Um,
so Satan,
Satan sees Satan sees all of this,
he sees this weird and bizarrely unstable sexual hierarchy in Milton's Eden.
And what does he say?
A line to 90 no wine.
Five 20 line.
Why five line five 21 at page two 90,
um,
Milton has Satan announced that he has your Rica.
I know how I'm going to do it.
He's arrived at his scheme to destroy Adam and eve,
and he says,
just having witnessed all of this Oh,
fair foundation laid where onto build their ruin,
I know how I'm going to be able to bring this place down.
Now,
Milton isn't eager to join Satan in this claim of God's injustice,
but he's willing to,
to expose the inherently unstable foundation of Eden sexual hierarchy.
Um,
okay.
Milton lays the foundation.
Ultimately,
I think,
as we'll see,
when we look read book nine,
he lays the foundation for our understanding of some of the deepest causes of
the fall.
Okay.
Remember for next time,
a big chunk of reading books,
five,
six,
seven and eight.